I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle thank you for being with us
tonight
colorblind with Rage that's the focus of
tonight's angle
Mr President thank you thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here
um we'll have reaction
well that was interesting
today we saw that Joe Biden has lost far
more than his awareness of basic
television etiquette
he's lost all credibility
after the Supreme Court's 6-3 decisions
striking down the use of racial
preferences and college admissions Biden
was sent out by whomever winds them up
to lie
affirmative action is so misunderstood
many people wrongly believe that
affirmative action allows unqualified
students unqualified students to be
admitted ahead of qualified students
this is not this is not how College
admissions work now the White House
comms people aren't that ignorant they
know the truth that the entire point of
racial preferences is to give minority
candidates an edge regardless of their
test scores or their transcripts the
resume it's classic discrimination and
it's based on race colleges set out
standards for admission and every
student every student has to meet those
standards then and only then after first
meeting the qualifications required by
the school do college look at other
factors in addition to their grades such
as race
okay what's less believable that he
didn't know that Hunter was making
millions off the Chinese or that he
doesn't know that affirmative action is
a total scam
how many of you know someone whose son
or daughter didn't even get wait listed
at a university despite having Stellar
grades maybe a Varsity Sport maybe High
SATs while a minority student in their
class with an average or maybe even a
below average academic record got in
it happens every season
thousands and thousands of times during
the application process no one is
standing up to speak
out against the injustices faced by our
community
with our well-deserved rights will never
realize
justices Thomas's concurrence in the
case was an absolute tour de force the
best piece of legal analysis in writing
I think I've ever read
he went right at the University's
Reliance on racial box checking in
admissions you have to read it
all racial categories he wrote are
little more than stereotypes suggesting
that immutable characteristics somehow
conclusively determine a person's
ideology beliefs and abilities
of course that's false members of the
same race do not all share the exact
same experiences and viewpoints far from
it a black person from rural Alabama
surely has different experiences than a
black person from Manhattan or a black
first generation immigrant from Nigeria
in the same way that a white person from
rural Vermont has a different
perspective than a white person from
Houston Texas
yet University's racial policies suggest
that racial identity alone constitutes
the being of the race or the man
that is the same naked racism upon which
segregation itself was built
Small Wonder then that all these
policies are leading to increasing
racial polarization and friction he
wrote
and that's the practices obviously not
just hideously unfair it's
constitutional under the equal
protection Clause the court found
unfair to non-minorities into the
minorities themselves
now here's more from Justice Thomas
he writes I continue to strongly believe
and have never doubted that blacks can
achieve in every Avenue of American life
without the meddling of University
administrators
meritocratic systems with objective
grading scales are critical to that
belief
such scales have always been a great
equalizer offering a metric for
achievement that bigotry could not alter
racial preferences take away this
benefit eliminating the very metric by
which those who have the most approve
can clearly demonstrate their
accomplishments both to themselves and
to others
he went on to discuss how historically
black colleges aren't diverse at all but
have been incredibly successful at
changing lives to the better in
educating generation after generation of
black students
not luck this case truth be told was not
even a close call
and at a time when it's rare to find a
strong consensus on any hot button issue
right now in America there's
overwhelming bipartisan opposition to
the use of racial preferences
a new New York Times poll shows that 78
percent of Republicans and 72 percent of
Independents and 58 percent of Democrats
say they oppose affirmative action at
private colleges and universities
a similar finding from the annual survey
by the scotus poll look at those numbers
wow wow
now certainly America most Americans
will be relieved by the Court's ruling
today but not everyone was happy just
look at these faces
now think about it they're mad that
universities can no longer discriminate
based on race
they're upset that the court followed
the original meaning of the equal
protection clause
they're mortified that their diversity
shell game has been exposed for what it
is not just unconstitutional but grossly
unfair stigmatizing and and frankly just
patronizing
for decades liberals leaned into the
diversity charades shaming colleges into
admissions to into using admissions to
right past wrongs and achieve a more
diverse student body
but despite all that all those years of
diversifying their conclusion now is
that America is somehow more racist than
ever
but they're finger-pointing about racism
is pointing right back at them
because with their reactions today we're
reminded that they are the most racist
and a tolerant bunch out there
and I'm telling you they will not give
up they never give up easy
in fact Biden's not sure that the
Court's decision is even the end of the
issue we cannot let this decision be the
last word I wanted we cannot let this
decision be the last word
can't can't let it go now what happened
to Reviving faith in our government Joe
and our democracy Mr President wasn't
that the whole shtick that you pulled in
but is the court now not part of all
that it's not part of the democratic
process last time I checked it was one
of the three branches of government
the angle suspects that many colleges
will try some clever moves to try to get
around this ruling or maybe I guess
maybe even try to ignore it all together
remember they only respect judicial
decisions they agree with maybe like the
gay marriage case or the state voting
rules cases handed down earlier this
week
as for the Constitution a lot of those
same radicals believe it's a document
that was written by a bunch of old dead
white guys so its words need to be kind
of like Silly Putty you can just Flex
them and stretch them as much as you
want to fit any situation
and if the court doesn't rule
accordingly well it's just illegitimate
the majority decided that race can only
be solved by ignoring what is so evident
in every aspect of Our Lives the ethics
and the scandals that hangs over the
core as well as the larger legitimacy
question I fear what will happen and
what will there be many lawyers who look
like Charles and I in the future or
doctors or accountants it is a problem
and it's not preferential treatment
now they can fume all they want
but it's one of the main forces behind
the case Edward Blom remarked today this
opinion marks the beginning of the
restoration of the colorblind legal
Covenant that binds together all
multiracial and our multi-ethnic nation
but not according to the deeply negative
view of America from the Court's newest
and arguably the most activist Justice
katanji Brown Jackson well
despite recusing herself from hearing
Harvard's companion case she decided to
chime in on the NC State decision
coming darn close to personally
attacking Justice Clarence Thomas who
wrote as I said that powerful
concurrence
Jackson accused him of having quote an
obsession with race Consciousness and
also this
she wrote the takeaway is that those who
demand no one think about race a classic
Pink Elephant Paradox refused to see
much less Saul for the elephant in the
room the race linked disparities that
continue to impede achievement of our
great great of our great our nation's
great potential our country she writes
has never been colorblind
Justice Clarence Thomas again in that
barn burner of a concurrence wrote a
devastating rebuke to follow Justice
Jackson
as she see things we are all inexorably
trapped in a fundamentally racist
Society with the original sin of slavery
and the historical subjugation of black
Americans still determining our lives
today
we're still Justice Jackson uses her
broad observations about statistical
relationships between race and select
measures of health wealth and well-being
to label all blacks as victims
her desire to do so
is unfathomable to me
are Americans to be perpetually divided
by race
the elites say yes
but a good majority of Americans and six
Supreme Court Justices on the court say
no
politicians who defend the racial spoils
system that has roiled so much of
American society they do so because they
want to keep the people scared and
divided
after Decades of Democrats in charge and
their fake appeals for racial healing
what's happened to Urban America it's
worse it's worse off not better off
healing real healing comes when all
Americans are treated equally without
regard to race
the left fears what we're building
a multi-racial multi-ethnic coalition
that believes in helping American
workers and upholding our constitution
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else